finish a sentence for me of all the
roles I've ever played Dalton Trumbo was
the most recent and we're done thank you
you know you think about this this guy
Dalton Trumbo he's someone who refused
to let any setback or circumstance stop
him from creating do you think about
moments in your career where you might
have had a setback and you didn't let it
stop you I'm forging ahead what would
some of those moments be um there are
many times when I would have I'd have my
survival jobs you know either waiting
tables or loading trucks things like
that well and you you you do it because
you need to do it you need to pay your
rent but your mind is pretty much on
someday I'm going to be able to call
myself an actor hmm and you just have to
weather the storm and have faith in what
you do and and determination and
perseverance patience and look you have
to have luck and that happened for me
when I was 25 years old and that is
still my my proudest professional
achievement is the day I I knew it
changed for me and from that point on I
never did anything other than act for
living and were there moments where you
ever felt like TV networks and movie
studios are only asking me to do this
one thing that I've already done five
times when I really want to do so my
other things how did you get through
those times you have to be able to say
the word no and and mean it but um you
know when when Malcolm in the Middle
left the air was seven years of playing
a silly sweet dad and I had a couple
offers to do just that on other TV
pilots that I politely said no by making
myself available by saying though I was
able to do Breaking Bad and and then it
life changes it all worked out yeah
there's a similarity between your career
and Dalton Trumbo sand that I would call
you both risk takers do you feel a
kinship with
in that regard I suppose anybody who who
ventures into the arts as as a
profession a life long journey I think
by Nature has to be somewhat of a risk
taker and so in that sense I would say
so but for me to pick and choose the
projects that I want to do now designed
by what I think I should do where I
should go and if something scares me a
little bit that's always a good sign but
if something feels like a comfortable
fit and I know I can walk in and just do
it and I don't need much work on it I
usually shy away from doing anything
like that anything that that doesn't
require a lot from me I'm not usually
interested in let's take a look at a
great scene from Trumbo this is a really
terrific confrontation that you have
with John Wayne played by david james
elliott let's take a look and see what
happens you won't get eat acres not here
anyway oh why is that all it says is
that Congress has no right to
investigate how we vote or where we pray
what we think say or how we make movies
hello I'm Dalton Trumbo Congress has the
right to go after anything they think is
a threat well that's where we disagree
and that's the point we both have the
right to be wrong well as the movie
tells you this is a dangerous time for
some people to be living in depending on
their political beliefs do you think
something like this could happen these
days and if so what would it look like
it can it does it we are constantly
reminded of the value and foundational
structure of free speech you know the
First Amendment was created not to
defend popular commentary but unpopular
commentary mmm these are important
issues to you I can tell they are they
are very important I'm curious about
opinions more often than um I'm more
curious about opinions that are opposite
of mine well let's see what happens with
this crime
stationed here I was curious that's the
second time you mentioned that say I was
a war correspondent in Okinawa ooh head
his son was stationed in the Philippines
Eddie he was in Europe with the Office
of War Information where did you serve
again you trying to say something no
Duke he wasn't stay out of it Eddie if
you're going to talk about World War two
as if you personally want it let's be
clear where you were stationed on a film
set shooting blanks wearing makeup and
if you're going to hit me I would like
to take off my glasses are you political
guy you go on your Twitter you're more
you're more comedic than political ah
but yeah I do like to engage and I think
the the problem that I think's happening
in America is the polemic nature of the
of the political system where it's a us
against them we've pulled away from a
sensible approach and mutual respect for
those who have a different opinion so I
want to bring that back i want it i want
to be able to look at someone and talk
to someone who i completely disagree
with but not lose respect for and know
that that person truly is intending to
make the society that we live in a
better place yeah that they're not
trying to destroy it it's just that we
think differently on how to approach it
and I think if we can get back to that
Sensibility I think more things will get
done and so if Trumbo has a message it's
that freedom of speech freedom of
assembly freedom to practice whatever
religion or be belonged to whatever a
political party you choose was
hard-fought rights that were one and
need to be protected I congratulate you
on this terrific performance it's like
really well done it's great to see you
thank you if you all have not seen
Trumbo be sure to check it out buy your
tickets on fandango and thank you very
much to the TCL chinese theaters imax
for having us today and thank you for
watching fandango frontrunners
you
Oh